what's going on guys this is Rob and
today I wanted to do a video discussing
the recent YouTube videos of a fight
between Superman and the Incredible Hulk
because I think this is actually a
pretty cool concept to the watch a
godown was actually pretty amazing it
was it was pretty enjoyable to watch but
I think that a lot of people in the
Marvel comics had this tendency to
discard Superman to say that Superman is
strong but he's not Marvel Comics strong
which I don't agree with I think this
Superman is a pretty powerful character
in and of himself despite the faculties
from DC when it comes to a fight a
knock-down drag-out brawl on an empty
planet between Superman and The
Incredible Hulk that's orbiting a Yellow
Sun in all honesty I would have to give
the fight to Superman and here's why in
the Marvel comics we've seen the
Incredible Hulk
powerful enough to withstand you know
planets exploding and to have the
strength powerful enough to shake the
entire eastern seaboard with a single
step but that's when when the Incredible
Hulk isn't a fully enraged state in
order for the Incredible Hulk to become
a credible threat to Superman he would
have to be completely enraged and in
order to do that he has to build up his
anger when Superman first shows up he's
already that strong we've seen comics
where Superman has pulled planets and
we've seen comics where Superman has
destroyed entire planets with a single
punch the power that he possesses is not
contingent on his emotional state and so
he doesn't have to build up to it so I
would say that if you saw a fight
between Superman and The Incredible Hulk
you'd probably see The Incredible Hulk
defeated in short order now does that
mean that I think this Superman could
kill The Incredible Hulk
I don't really think so just because
when you're talking about the Incredible
Hulk you're talking about the ability
for him to heal from any virtually any
kind of damage the Superman could deal
to him shy of maybe having his laser
beams blasted through his head or
something like that but as far as
initial confrontations that thing you'd
see that hoped if he did pretty fast you
know quite swiftly just because Superman
is is incredibly strong and it's funny
because a lot of people don't see it
that way but when you look at the Marvel
comic
and you'd kind of do a comparison to DC
Comics you see a lot of similar
counterparts you see a lot of similarity
between two different characters I mean
for example and Marvel you have Galactus
this world eater he just travels from
planet to planet devouring the life
force of that planet and then moves on
to the next and in DC you had imperiex
this being that was hunting for
imperfection and the cosmos and would
travel from you know solar system to
solar system destroying everything
trying to find this imperfection and you
know it actually turned out he was the
imperfection himself but nonetheless you
know when you look at Superman you have
like the century in Marvel Comics or
gladiator from the Shiar Shiar Empire in
Marvel Comics you know you look at the
Incredible Hulk and you have doomsday
you know I don't really think it's it's
appropriate to look at one character in
Marvel Comics or in DC Comics and to
discard them simply because you perceive
there to be other characters in a
different comic book developer I guess
who are powerful for all intents and
purposes or more powerful for instance
and purposes I mean I could easily make
an argument and say okay then let's say
we have the Incredible Hulk fighting
Superman prime well it'd be hands down
at that point you know let's say that we
have the century fighting super let's
say we have virtually anybody in the
Marvel Comics shy of Franklin Richards
or the Scarlet Witch or the Phoenix
force fighting Superman prime it'd be
pretty much hands-down I mean Superman
prime would take it to him in short
order so you know everybody each comic
has their own variant of a particular
character who possesses the highest
level of possible strength relative to
their character so I think that at the
end of the day we just kind of just sit
back and say that was a badass series of
videos and the laughs about it and and
talk about it and have this great debate
but but yeah as far as my my pick goes
if you're talking about a fight between
Superman and The Incredible Hulk then it
goes to Superman
so with that being said I will catch you
guys later peace